Này nhạm mới tìm mình thấy là
Chơi ngồi tại sao lúc cao như thế này mà
cả khoảng tin lập trên mình
đó là cái
và bây giờ làm thế nào mà chí trong con
một số tháng mà mình họ thấy
xác sổ được bây giờ thì
cái đầu tiên mà chị có thể làm được tại thôi điểm đời
hồi cái hậu cái tài chính là giây hồ để là chị
ngay lập thức tăng kể để tết kiểm
của mình lên
Chúc đây thì
bởi vì mình đang sống trong cái bòng rất hãng
và mình không có một cái mục tiêu nào cả những
tù lập ý tào thì mình cũng sẽ tự
là hài lòng thì chỉ sẽ chí tiêu như hồn
mình sẽ tiếp tục ở phần dự lại thôi
và chỉ rất là bất ngờ người là
khi mà mình có một cái mục tiêu rồi
đắt trước mà khi thế thì
ngay lập thức là mình sẽ kẹo ra nhiều
mình sẽ kẹo được nhiều hơn ra nhiều
sau với tất cả người ta ăn trước bộ lại
khi mà có một cái mục tiêu người thế
mình đã nhận ra là
tết kiểm người thế này thì không thì nó đã được
một tiêu thế việc của chị là
trong thời tiêu người đầy là
cho cái chí tiêu thế
và tất cả chí
tính hiểu với
lâu cứu在 hãng và chị
lâu cứu là những cái tụi mà
chị thực sự hiểu biết
thì chị nghĩa sao đấy
có thể gây chàng nghiệm là
thì chị thấy là
sự xếp kiểm của mình
có người thông trở của mình không tiếp tượng đường
ở vỉ
họ có một tiêu
khi mà họ mà mục tiêu rồi
thì mình sẽ cảm thấy cho
và phải xem thịt kiểm thịt
thì thịt thiêu
có ý nghĩa gì đâu luôn
mà người thế nó là cái hiểu ứng kiểu
và là tại và cái thứ là mỗi
một số trách chi tiêu đi ở bản nghĩ là
không ở bên đây gì đâu
nhiều cái lần chi tiêu đi ở khoảng nắng như thế thì nó tạo ra một cái
hợp 1 thất lo